con una ceremonia privada la velación de
javier ordóñez se realizó una semana
después de su muerte el cuerpo del
hombre de 43 años fue entregado el
pasado viernes las exequias se
retrasaron mientras llegaban algunos
familiares que viven en otros países sus
allegados le dieron un último adiós y
aún no entienden la brutalidad de los
dos policías que lo detuvieron en la
madrugada del miércoles 9 de septiembre
en realidad
lo que todos esperamos
[Música]
que paguen una justicia como debe ser
solo pues un procedimiento policial de
vino con gas al final
lo mataron
la verdad yo no pude verle el cuerpo yo
solo garcía a ver el rostro
y en puesto el rostro estaba totalmente
golpe a buscar tenía hematomas
en el rostro
el cuerpo de ordóñez presentó
contusiones en la cabeza costillas
fracturadas y el hígado reventado la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez se
refirió a su muerte como un asesinato el
clamor por que haya justicia en este
caso se extendió por todo colombia
decenas de protestas contra la violencia
policial se registraron en varias
ciudades del país en 48 horas los
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y la
policía dejaron 13 muertos y más de 400
heridos ahora en el senado colombiano se
debate una vez más sobre una reforma
estructural a la policía de colombia en
el congreso hay varias propuestas como
cambios en las prácticas de los
oficiales y que el organismo quede a
cargo del ministerio del interior- y no
del de defensa como es actualmente pero
habrá que esperar si se logra una
mayoría para que la discusión empiece
luego de que el presidente colombiano
iván duque se negara a acoger una
propuesta de reforma